ragazzi siamo tornati ragazzi su venerdì
13 proprio perché oggi è venerdì 13 da
tradizione quando cioè i 13 faccio verdi
13 è l'unico video che non c'è bisogno
di pensare per farlo non può uscire
altro oggi sono queste ragazzine
elettrici da un po che non gioco perché
c'è un venerdì 13 in media un paio di
volte l'anno ne che c'è chissà quante
volte no che li passano più o meno
cinque o sei mesi ogni volta che faccio
vedere i tre li vediamo se mi ricordo
come si fa perché partita i ragazzi
quanti cazzo si aspetta per di 1 su 28
bella aiscat bacheca un attimo sono
entrato adesso ragazze possibile che c'è
sta qua lo zio subito sono entrato siamo
in 28 che succede ragazzi a sta
succedendo tia porta chi hackett ha
fatti cioè mi spiegherà attimo perché
che cosa che sta succedendo ragazzi ma
quanta gente c'è stanno girando aglione
non è possibile
cosa succede qua saggio in aldo gen che
penso sia una partita che rata non so
salve una persona qui
rumori che non vado via arrivederci sono
più gente ecco com'è possibile che c'è
tutta stagione ci sono un miliardo di
gesù domanda esistono le robe per
scappare si può scappare o siamo succubi
di sti stronzi che dobbiamo c'è una
lucina rossa gli succede usa alberto
buongiorno ai la batteria ecco qua io
prendo sto tronco gigante vieni con me
non sul fuoco vieni via e metti la
batteria nella macchina nella macchina
c'è una macchina qua metti la roba nella
macchina per faccio un'altra mantegazzi
ma che ci sono ma si può vedere la mappa
si sono 1 2 3 4 macchine ma charge view
che è
ma cos'è che c'avete sono spaventato a
morte ma non ho visto anche perché sono
spaventato a morte lo è successo
ecco perché sospettata forte che sta a
jason dietro in ammazza gli altri
elevato alla messa la batteria lo zio
qua io c'ho la tanica però non la metto
finché non se ne sta andando doveva lo
zio vi prego guardate la mia faccia ma
che anche gente sta spaccando tutti vado
a metà tanica non va da mentana tanica
perché ce lo zio che stavo
io me le varie l'ex unicamente quando mi
vedo vai via vai via vai via di qua che
sto aspettando di parlare dove la tanica
oti rilevare madonna guardai vi ha
attirato via chiedo metà la tanica sulla
marcia abbiamo più me ne vado ad
un'altra macchina signorina lascio ti
lasciamo combattere 22 meritano c'è una
macchina in movimento attenzione possa
darmi non lascia la mafia che certamente
lati player che c'è effettivamente una
macchina in movimento la vita se
riusciamo a prenderla si schianta a
rossi sarà sta seguendo l'altro jason ma
quella barca ragazzi sto giocasta anche
un po allargando perché sarà il 51
players giustamente aspetta che ho
trovato avendo trovato la tanica se io
piccola tra la batteria sala
mancata michael bailey è tutto uno che
ho io manca scuola ha posto la facciamo
fermi city faccio io a gas a posto tutto
ok arrivederci drago cosa succede lì
cos'è questo c'è uno che vola e
arrivederci e stato percio e jason
laggiù speriamo che di non prendere
jason mi dovrei fare un giro da un'altra
parte
adesso dopo in un bar vado a sinistra
vado ad essere bloccare i white list
pensi a van goof
stato minato io direi di togliere a chi
nei ritorni è la gente si deve togliere
ma di qua a jannacci qualcuno tutti
già
ce l'ho fatta c'era gente perché se ha
trasportato lì ammazzato 1 me ne sono
andato
l'unico sopravvissuto di tutta la
partita pazzesca dei ragazzi facevano
un'altra aggiustato la partita nel del
giorno la migliore partita libera di 3g
da quando gioco a meredith regimi da sei
anni più o meno allo ragazzi siamo in
un'altra partita che è quella di prima
porta però sembra essere la stessa
partita o stanno spaccando la macchina e
la partita di prima ma perché mi mette
qua ma cosa vedo vedo rope nove ragazzi
non hanno attirato la lobby cioè
pazzesca sta roba anno ha chiamato a
lobby perché non si spiega niente di
tutto questo posso entrare quasi ecco
qua davanti io per favore grazie a
ryanair c io sto qua aspetto che
qualcuno guidi magari cio culo e
riusciamo ad andarsene magari qualcuno
si si si mette a fare qualcosa no mi ha
preso gesto che peccato ma nasce e vabbè
niente ma spaccati sul sulla staccionata
beh la prima partita dove riesco a
vincere perdere nella stessa partita
come possibile cioè incredibile sotto
questo ci siamo ragazzi un'altra partita
nuovissima siamo sempre qua niente
c'è tutto tranne le chiavi no ragazzi
come capisco e con le chiavi e ne vado
qualcuna le chiavi non mi faccia lì a ok
posto la scavo quando il ciclo di solo
in una macchina per l'essere prestarmi
jason a 16 in basso e l'altro sta sempre
là in alto quindi le scorte da zio devi
andare devi fare tutta la strada di
bianco sta comunque quando jason è
difficile dimessi del destino sbattete
bravo così si gioca su bravo ragazzo vai
a sinistra si sta perché dà il suo
placet esista c'è una stradina può la
vedi white square no non è la sola
facciata di andata a sinistra di lance
jesolo di tagliare la strada ad ora i
porca [ __ ] no di qua madonna lady
madonna ma poi può essere così scarsa
non esiste non ci credono degli italiani
di andare a sinistra
set un cazzo perché cesta jason lee che
gli esordi dove passi io veramente per
dare quanti anni hai zero come file
avere zero iq va da un'altra parte c'è
jason ormai a destra si va ai tuoi cazzo
vuoi ma non lì c'è una mappa vai dove
vuoi
no non ci guarda guarda un demente
scendi dalla macchina ti prego mi
rifiuto mi rifiuto di credito ci è
impossibile
come fai essere così deficiente non
andare su gesù dio santissimo ne vado
lascio ti lascio venire posso ci posso
posso scendere dalla napoli share bravo
bravo bravissimo
incredibile
300 iq ritiro tutto fenomeno ritiro
tutto fenomeno la bravissima era il
miglior giocatore
scherzavo scherzavo voglio solo vedere
perché alla fine arriva anche la polizia
quindi a quel punto scappa anche con la
polizia ha visto che già vinto due volte
la stessa partita c'è la polizia
perché ciò si sono vestiti randomizzati
i personaggi adesso va bene la polizia
dovrebbe essere dove sta l'altro jason
quasi kiss
teoricamente adesso non lo so però
immagino che sia qua dove ci stanno
questi qua che stanno impalati
aspettando i giornalisti pacchi la
facciano atterrato sceso un fantastico
bravi ragazzi continuate così mentre io
me ne vado a vincere l'unico ci sono 62
player sono io davanti a cesena c'è una
sfiga tremenda e la lo vedo lo vedo
nella mappa sta aspettando gente che
passi da lì giusto un sta arrivando la
macchina e 3000 allora eccola lo zio
otto
o spettatore rilassa la pacchia la casa
riesco
ho pensato la macchina come come
diversivo per scappata nel 2000 i cui
ragazzi credibili signori questa è la
vena di 13 e oggi ne di 13 spero che vi
sia piaciuto il libro per me è stata una
figata è stato incredibile però ragazzi
speriamo il prossimo editrici appunto
per il nostro consueto appuntamento
iscrivetevi consueta chiare se vi è
piaciuto questo momento io mi piace e
noi come sempre ci vediamo al
professionismo e ragazzi
[Musica]